[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à l'entretien sur
France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui est
John dounda l'ancien rédacteur en chef
de Joe morei
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
c'est un plaisir d'être avec vous merci
en 2016 vous avez été condamné à 5 ans
de prison pour avoir publié une vidéo
prétendant montrer une contrebande
d'armes turques destinées à des
djihadistes en Syrie
pour l'Allemagne en 2016 parce que vous
avez été traduit en justice et qu'il y a
une tentative d'attentat contre vous
pendant ce procès et en décembre 2020
vous avez été condamné en absence à 20
ans de prison sur des charges
d'espionnage et d'aide à une
organisation terroriste il semble
toutefois que ça a toujours été une
affaire très personnelle entre vous
between et Ratchet
est-ce que il a pris tellement
personnellement cette affaire
et bien cela va très au-delà de mon
affaire personnelle c'est plutôt Erdogan
contre les médias turcs contre les
médias turcs libres il y a aussi une
dimension personnelle parce que mon
enquête portait sur le fait que le
gouvernement turc était en train d'aider
des terroristes djihadistes en Syrie et
leur faisait acheminer des armes de
façon clandestine et
erdoğan était pris la main dans le sac
et ça ne lui a pas du tout plus c'est ça
l'explication de toute cette affaire
mais au-delà de ça tout ce qui va à
l'encontre des intérêts du gouvernement
ou d'Erdogan personnellement et
considéré comme un attentat contre
l'État et il le présente à la peau
population comme étant de la trahison
et c'est ce que vous retrouverez partout
dans n'importe quel régime autoritaire
si vous
remettez en cause les intérêts du
gouvernement vous serez taxés de
terroristes ou de personnes qui est son
propre pays
en Allemagne mais du nouveau après ces
révélations vos révélations le président
de Gan dit je le cite vous devez payer
le prix après que vous ayez été libéré
vous avez vous êtes moqués de la Cour
constitutionnelle et bien que vous soyez
en Allemagne il a demandé votre
extradition ça n'a pas abouti ça a été
rejeté mais est-ce que vous sentez
menacé même physiquement alors que vous
êtes en Allemagne
malheureusement oui parce que
erdouane a le bras long en Europe et
dans beaucoup d'autres pays du monde
occidental
il bluff il fait du chantage au
gouvernement européen en demandant
l'extradition de Jean comme moi et
malheureusement parfois cela fonctionne
dans mon cas bien sûr
il y a un certain nombre d'actions qui
ont été lancés par le gouvernement turc
pour me récupérer ils essaient
d'utiliser Interpol et dans le même
temps bien sûr il y a un certain nombre
de soutien d'air douane qui vivent dans
le même pays que moi qui essaye disons
de me rendre la vie compliquée et donc
même si je vis en Allemagne je ne me
sens pas totalement libre bien sûr
le bureau du procureur général
d'Istanbul a ouvert une enquête contre
vous pour je cite insulte au président
et insultes à la nation turque
cet article de loi a été utilisé de plus
en plus mais est-ce que vous le voyez
comme un signal que très clairement on
ne nous a pas oublié là-bas
il y a des milliers de cas d'outrages au
président en Turquie si vous écrivez
quelque chose si vous dites quelque
chose contre le président turc vous êtes
traité comme un criminel et comme il n'y
a plus d'état de droits ce pays tous les
procureurs travaillent pour erdoine et
font le maximum pour punir les critiques
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement banal il y a également une
autre affaire puisque récemment j'ai été
condamné pour avoir provoqué la
manifestation de ghezy qui remonte à
2013 donc il y a tout un tas d'affaires
et dès que vous remettez en cause un
leader tel kerdoğan vous devez être prêt
à subir des conséquences de ce type
alors que nous sommes en train de parler
nous savons que la Turquie négocie avec
la Finlande et la Suède pour extrader
des personnes qu'elle recherche
échange de l'entrée de ces pays dans
l'autre temps êtes-vous inquiet de
l'utilisation pour la Turquie de
questions comme d'arguments comme
l'appartenance à l'OTAN ou ce qui se
passe en Ukraine pour obtenir des
personnes qu'elle poursuit comme vous
d'ailleurs
oui exactement c'est tout à fait la
tactique qu'utilise
Erdogan qui l'utilise depuis des années
malheureusement c'est la fonction très
bien
la dernière façon de faire c'est
l'utilisation de l'OTAN comme vous le
savez il a essayé de bloquer l'adhésion
de la Suède et de la Finlande à l'OTAN
et en échange il a demandé à ce que
certains de ses opposants soient
extradés de ces deux pays et au départ
je ne pensais pas qu'ils allaient aider
R2 one mais bien entendu dès qu'il
s'agit de questions de sécurité et bien
les questions de droit de l'homme risque
toujours de devenir un peu secondaire et
en l'occurrence suait la Suède pour
erdoğan a décidé de changer sa
constitution et sa définition du
terrorisme pour donner à Ardouane ce
qu'il voulait et c'est vraiment là
quelque chose de honte j'aimerais voir
les pays européens défendre leurs idéaux
et refuser le chantage d'erdoğan
comment décririez-vous la situation des
médias dans votre pays la Turquie a été
classée 149e sur 180 pays dans l'indice
de liberté de la presse de Reporters
sans frontières pour 2022 reporter sans
frontières suit la Turquie très
attentivement de très près et comme elle
l'a dit dans son rapport effectivement
la situation des médias en Turquie est
en train d'empirer année après année
Erde est devenu le Mania numéro 1 des
médias en Turquie il possède les médias
des hommes d'affaires très proches de
lui ont acheté des médias en Turquie et
près de 80% des médias turcs sont
aujourd'hui entre les mains d'Erdogan le
reste est soit menacé de se retrouver en
prison soit déjà en prison il ne reste
que les médias sociaux les réseaux
sociaux dans notre pays et les en exil
comme le nôtre et soit nous sommes
bloqués soit avec la nouvelle loi sur
les médias il essaye de bloquer les
réseaux sociaux juste avant l'élection
vous venez de mentionner ce que vous
allez vous poser comme question une
nouvelle loi vient d'être votée par le
Parlement en octobre que qui pourrait
voir des journalistes ou des
utilisateurs de réseaux sociaux
emprisonnés jusqu'à 3 ans pour
dissémination de ce qui serait qualifié
de fausses nouvelles est-ce que ce
serait un instrument grâce auquel le
régime pourrait véritablement
museler même des médias en exil ou des
mauvais réseaux sociaux
loi sur la désinformation mais là nous
sommes vraiment dans le roman de George
Orwell 1984 avec son ministère de la
Vérité il ne s'agit pas ici de supprimer
de fausses informations mais dans
diffuser en faveur de gouvernement et
d'essayer d'empêcher les journalistes
qui informent le public de faire leur
travail d'empêcher ces journalistes de
données au public des informations
fiables il s'en est d'abord pris aux
organes de presse et maintenant il est
en train d'attaquer les réseaux sociaux
il est très facile de reprocher à
quelqu'un d'avoir produit des fausses
informations car donner le bon chiffre
sur le taux d'inflation ou sur les cas
de coronavirus tout ça peut être regardé
comme étant de la fausse information de
fausses informations et peut vous mener
en prison donc c'est en train de créer
une vraie peur dans la population donc
non seulement le gouvernement turc nous
entrave dans notre travail mais fait
peur également au turc pour qu'il
n'aille pas sur nous sites internet ou
sur nos comptes de réseaux sociaux hors
comme nous le disions il n'y a plus que
6 mois d'ici les élections et c'est en
train de donner à
r2hane un avantage énorme que de bloquer
ces informations fiables juste avant les
élections
les projections montrent que les
élections seront très serrées en raison
de la mauvaise situation économique
est-ce que vous craignez que la
couverture de ces élections ne soient
pas honnêtes ou même que l'élection
elle-même ne soit pas honnête et
transparente
alors il faut quand même que vous vous
rendiez compte que on parle d'un pays où
il n'y a plus d'état de droits le
système judiciaire est contrôlé par le
gouvernement on peut en dire autant des
médias et donc R2A à le pouvoir
parlementaire judiciaire médiatique
Falls militaire policier
comment lutter contre un leader aussi
totalitaire alors que nous n'avons pas
d'outils pour lutter contre lui donc
sans
une presse libre et un système
judiciaire fonctionnel il nous est très
difficile de lutter contre contre le
régime
et malgré tout cela et bien qu'il est
tous les pouvoirs presque toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion montrent que il
risque de perdre ses élections et c'est
pourquoi il fait son maximum pour rester
au pouvoir je suis persuadé que
l'oppression va encore s'aggraver dans
les mois à venir
il a annoncé qu'il allait lancer une
opération militaire contre la Syrie il a
menacé la Grèce pas plus tard qu'hier il
essaye de créer une sorte d'atmosphère
chaotique pour convaincre les gens que
ils ont besoin d'un homme fort plutôt
que d'un gouvernement de coalition
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de
l'entretien sur France 24 et merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi
[Musique]